et parfois l'amour et à quelques mètres
d'eux soit il ne le voit pas
[Musique]
ici tarek
ya quelqu'un
[Rires]
il y a quelqu'un qui a envoyé un des
responsables de l'émission je te lis le
texto bonjour fabien je suis en train de
travailler sur l'émission de ce soir je
me demandais si t'arrives boudali
étaient présents oui il sera en plateau
c'est prévu pourquoi des choses pour
rien mais tu connais mes goûts
s'arrêtant de away t'en fous tu m'as
jamais rien c'est surtout ce qui est
plus grand que c'est la dernière fois je
balance jamais rien série
c tarek
j'ai toujours voulu le mieux pour toi le
meilleur
cheval meilleur dans ta carrière le
meilleur dans ta vie le meilleur banc
pas encore battu le meilleur dans ton
coeur la police pense qu'il est libre
ici il ya peu de célibataire et toi tu
as la chance
d'avoir une des célibataires de
l'émission qui a son petit coeur qui bat
ne paye pas pour toi mais tu sais pas si
je suis célibataire si je n'ai pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si si
il ya
tu sois célibataire ou pas il faut
toujours laisser la porte entrouverte
quand il ya déjà quelqu'un dans la
maison
la forêt
non c'est la forêt l'agent immobilier
daniel
je sais que ce soir elle était mise sur
ton temps tu es un bon ami la veste que
patrick sébastien portée lors du grand
cabaret
magnifique cette veste avec laquelle il
a chanté le petit bonhomme en mousse
et tu t'es dit aujourd'hui je vais la
mettre pour forcer le destin
l'areq totu magnifier les rayures ouais
mais rares 19 vraiment c'est frais c'est
magnifique ces bagnards ces bagnards
mais
sortait un peu vous alors boutique pour
vous attend
thomas coutrot combattants l'aquagym
merci la tenue de guillaume est pas mal
c'est un peu la première tenue nft ouais
c'est vrai t'as raison c'est vrai sur 10
connaissent de bons débats et d'éviter
sa tenue
allez-vous changer non
merci
tarek à
judy
daniel a préparé une danse pour toi
c'est
super super héros malgré lui sort demain
tu vas être c'est pas un super héros
malgré toi c'est ça ce que daniel vous
répondre et ce qu'elle sait faire avec
son corps génial daniel ses huit ans de
pole dance
ces neuf ans chez paul le boulanger
si ces pôles ont également 11 ans 11 ans
on va le dire osler un club destatis
daniel ce soir c'est le soir
daniel c'est le il est 19 heures cap on
est en direct et c'est peut-être un
tournant de sa vie sentimentale
direct quand il ne dit rien comme ça je
le connais c'est qu'il est en train de
se dire
sortir c'est pourquoi pas bien entendu
les mulets l'areq est ému tard il se dit
même être déjà à temps je veux savoir un
truc est ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que
c'est alain c'est vrai avec sa sélection
je vous confirme que c'est vrai parce
que je sais qui c'est vrai que je peux
préciser quand même nom aussi le précise
le président ne présage rien n'est fait
encore parler
mais
dans le film une ouverture parce qu'il
est avec une lame hammond son copain oui
c'est ça voilà je me dis quelquefois
alors il avec sa maman pas avec la grand
maman
maman il faut que savoir voilà voilées
des générations quoi de génération lire
allons forcément apparemment que sa
salle samedi parents marie danielle et
ma famille mais là n'est pas le moment
de plus value
oui pour l'instant tu restes assis
profite
pour le pôle danse j'ai besoin d'une
barre alors
voilà déjà une dans les bars ici dans
cette émission on en trouve à monsieur
eux-mêmes une toute petit bar yam aja
on met lass et une perdure dans sa forme
et je suis là à la veille de chaque côté
danse avec toi
approche mais ça m'amuse pas
[Musique]
et
c'est pas
qui
[Applaudissements]
fonder ebra bodart et
chimie mais c'est plus lui c'est plus
qu'une alchimie
voilà j'ai vu j'ai vu sa vie comme quand
on sait que quand vous êtes en tp de
chimie à l'école y avait un précipité
rouge qui merci à la lumière blanc je
sais plus mais j'ai vu un truc j'ai vu
quelque chose qui est mis en dépôt
je vais apprécier péter j'ai vu quelque
chose